we begin then with that breaking news
from france an orthodox priest has been
shot and wounded in lyon
the priest was fired on twice as he was
closing the church
the attacker reportedly fled the scene
it follows the killing of three people
at a church in nice
on thursday al jazeera's david chater is
in nice he's with us now david talk us
through
what we know of what happened earlier in
leon
yes this happened at the greek orthodox
church in lyon
the priest was just closing the doors
locking up
when an assailant approached with a sawn
off shotgun
and let two shots off into his abdomen
neighbors heard those explosions and
then they heard the
screaming of the priest the assailant
and then
ran away without saying anything to the
priest the police
moved in very quickly they had to treat
the priest on the ground first they had
to stem the bleeding then they have to
stop the shock
then they have to give him painkillers
but keep him stable there
until an ambulance arrived to take him
to the hospital he's now in the hospital
but the gunman
and the sawn off shotgun still at large
in the city of lyon there's a huge
police presence there now
they've taped off all the streets around
they are looking
uh seeking out this man warning people
that he is dangerous that he could still
launch
another attack so a really alarming
situation
there in lyon coming just two days or so
after
the attack on the basilica behind me yet
another christian
symbol being attacked this david despite
the fact that the country
has raised its threat level
that's right what that means raising its
threat level to urgent that's the top
threat level here in france it's meant
that they've put a lot more patrols on
the street here around this basilica
i noticed this morning large
reinforcements
of police with uh assault rifles also on
the breach
the promenades anglais just a few 800
yards or so away from here
there were more patrols i saw army
patrols as well now this is
not just going on here and nice
protecting the
churches and the schools it's going on
everywhere they're going to put more
than
four thousand more troops as part of
operation sentinel
onto the ground in patrols in france
more police
units just about everywhere they can
because
it's been promised that places of
worship and schools
anywhere where there are vulnerable
people who might be attacked
the police and the army will do their
very best to try and protect
them but as we've seen in lyon that's
not an easy task
there's just too many sites that could
be attacked
if they're going to be attacked and they
are expecting more attacks
it's a very tough a few days ahead both
for the people of france
and its security forces and its
government al jazeera's david chater
reporting live there
from niece david mini thanks indeed will
protesters in pakistan's biggest city
of bert effigies of francis president